et nous avons retrouvé franck delvaux co
président de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie à paris ile
de france a les restaurateurs que vous
représentez prépare donc un recours
contre la fermeture de leur
établissement en cette fin d'année
stratégique pour les commerçants comme
tous les ans est-ce que rouvrir au 1er
décembre vous permettrait de limiter les
dégâts alors on sait qu'on sera pas
ouvert au 1er décembre puisque le
premier ministre lors de son allocution
a pris 10 secondes pour parler news à
zapper mais sur ces 10 secondes il a
clairement dit comme celle pas ouvert au
1er décembre
alors effectivement pourquoi un recours
parce qu'il ya une rupture ou la vie
d'yves dans votre propre d'un reportage
du principe d'égalité
c'est à colorer la restauration
collective est ouverte
donc il faut nous expliquer pourquoi
chez nous en restauration commerciale
malgré notre protocole sanitaires très
strictes je le rappelle on peut attraper
le coville et on ne peut pas attraper
dans un restaurant d'entreprise c'est
les mêmes c'est les mêmes personnes
la personne va déjeuner le midi temps
restant d'entreprise et le soir dans un
dans un récente qu'on peut appeler type
commercial
pourquoi cette différence non on attaque
on fait surtout pour ça faut qu'on nous
l'expliquent selon voilà le protocole
sanitaire qui a été mise en place
avant leur confinement dans les
établissements il était suffisant pour
laisser les les restaurants ouverts est
ce qu'un renforcement de ces mesures
serait envisageable
le protocole sanitaire a déjà été
renforcée puisque on a limité les tables
à 6 couverts par table ans maximum
l'encaissement doit se faire à table et
on avait mis en place le cahier de
rappel on voyait on est allé déjà très
loin dans le protocole sanitaire
donc maintenant on le renforcer et non
si on le renforce encore alors mieux
vaut rester fermés puisque en plus vous
étant donné la météo on ne peut plus
avoir accès à notre terrasse donc
aujourd'hui il est déjà très renforcée à
95%
les professionnels le suivent c'est à
l'état de fermer les 5% qui ne veulent
pas respecter protocole sanitaire qu'est
ce qui est le plus compliqué pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est d'être fermés ou
n'avoir aucune visibilité le stop and go
et est le plus difficile à gérer
vous avez raison c'est le stop and go
qui est très dur à gérer
je vous rappelle que depuis le mois de
mars on a été confiné
ensuite en un revers uniquement les
terrasses ensuite on a pu rouvrir nos
salles ensuite on a eu le couvre-feu
maintenant de nouveau le confinement et
aucune perspective
on ne sait pas le gouvernement ne nous a
toujours pas dit quand est ce qu'on va
réouvrir ce sera quand ce sera 18
décembre ce sera au mois de janvier au
mois de février
alors je profite si vous permettez de
votre antenne pour rappeler nos le
problème des loyers dans nos entreprises
la mesure est de bruno le maire ne nous
satisfait pas nous on demande la
gratuité des loyers sur le dernier
trimestre
sinon nous aurons 30 à 50% de dépôt de
bilan dans notre profession
les matières sont donc insuffisante
aujourd'hui les mesures de l'état est ce
que malgré tout ce n'est pas grâce à
elle que les restaurateurs jusque là
arrive plus ou moins tenir
oui plus ou moins mais aujourd'hui on
est plus dans le plus on est dans le
moins
et si on n'a pas cette prise en charge
des loyers sachant qu'on n'a pas de
perspective de réouverture on ne va pas
s'en sortir c'est pas possible
donc aujourd'hui c'est très important
prises en charges de loyer comment
est-ce que vous évaluer les dégâts liés
au confinement n'ont donc dans votre
milieu
combien de professionnels ont dû mettre
la clé sous la porte depuis le début de
l'épidémie
quelques-uns c'est pas encore si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on a eu on a eu des
prêts garantis par l'état on a le
chômage partiel donc le prêt garanti par
l'état on n'a pas commencé à le
rembourser
c'est un moment des remboursements et si
rien n'est fait je suis désolé de le
répéter sur les met sur les loyers que
la du dépôt de bilan vont arriver c'est
dans deux mois au moment où les
bailleurs vont nous diabète alemanno
font payer loyer comment on fait on a pu
leur entrée
bien oui il ya le fonds de solidarité on
va nous toucher dix mille euros
puisqu'on est fermé mais c'est pas
suffisant dans un restaurant il ya des
charges fixes merci d'avoir pris le
temps de réagir sur notre antenne sur
notre antenne et pardon pour cette
connexion un peu compliqué franck
delvaux co président de l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
appareil le france